if you need more video games to play
good news the next games with gold
lineup has been announced if you're an
Xbox Live Gold member and want to know
what you can grab for free in June I've
got you covered
first up on Xbox one is Shantae and the
pirate's curse the third game in the
platforming series Shantae teams up with
her rival risky boots to battle pirate
master and you'll do so using a variety
of swashbuckling tools like a scimitar
and levitating hat Shantae will be
available to download all month long
Xbox ones other free game is coffee talk
as the name might tell you this is a
visual novel but you're not just talking
to regular humans coffee talk is set in
a fantasy version of Seattle with elves
mermaids and more stopping by the shop
it'll be available to download from June
16th through July 15th don't tune out
just yet
these 360 games are backwards compatible
for you Xbox one players - the first of
these is actually an original Xbox game
that was already backwards compatible on
360 Destroy All Humans
you play as crypto an alien invader
whose goal is to gather human DNA from a
small town using all sorts of space
gadgets and weapons it'll be available
from June 1st through the 15th just
before the remake launches in July
finally there's sin amaura this
side-scrolling shoot-'em-up has four
different difficulty levels to master
and they really do ramp up your ship
doesn't take damage though instead every
hit you take reduces the time limit for
completing each level take out enemies
to earn that time back
sinem aura will be available June 16th
through the 30th and those are your free
games with gold for June 2020 remember
that you can always check out gameplay
clips and reviews for these titles on
GameSpot and stay tuned as we report on
the new games with gold lineup every
month
[Music]
[Music]